let's jump to the next segment which is
which is an old story but is all too
fascinating yeah all too fascinating so
interesting this is a story from August
many of you you may have seen the story
when it came out it says too many people
think satirical news is real this story
is based on a lie of fabrication and
we're gonna show you the proof now
what's interesting about this is Adams
saw the story and you so this is the
conversation right yeah and I'm not
saying it's the fault in any way well no
no I I just looked at this and I was
like this is a good conversation right
you know but here's the thing while I
think it's fair to say too many people
do think satirical news is real that's a
fair opinion yeah this story itself is
fake but here's here's what gets crazy
this story is certified by the third
party agency that I use called news
guard I love giving them a shout-out
they're not perfect what they do is that
they give news outlets a a rating
essentially we can't you can see here
you've got green checkmarks across the
board except where it says handles the
difference between news and opinion
responsible right right that's kind of
exactly what you're calling them out on
right no no no I'm calling out Snopes oh
I'll show y'all so I see we yeah I
remember your explain them so basically
as far as I could tell okay this is a
legitimate news organization they are
certified by a third-party company of
journalists to subdue guard has a
subscription service where they
basically let you know what their rating
is they're not perfect I think they get
some I think they get a lot wrong okay
here they've given the conversation
Green across the board but this story is
overt fake news and here's what's what's
why this story was so funny when you
when you mentioned it I was like oh that
is a good that is a good story I pull it
up I'm looking at it and sure enough I
see these graphs saying Republicans are
more likely to believe fake news or
liberals or Democrats are more likely to
believe fakeness from the onion
conservatives Republicans from the
bailet Babylon be right the whole thing
is fake it's a manipulation okay it's an
incredible manipulation so what here's
oh the graphs themselves
the graphs are fake because I mean I'm
back into Twitter I'm kind of knew back
in this Twitter game and I saw an
article by Babylon B and I didn't know
it was that terrible because I don't I
didn't know
Babylon B was what was the story I don't
remember what it was do you remember it
was because I looked at you and I was
like is this real and you're like oh
that's Babylon being now I was like oh
yeah that was really interesting so I
know cuz he read he actually read me a
headline I was like I was like this like
that's Babylon B isn't it I'm like I was
like that makes sense cuz I it was so
crazy I was like but it it was
borderline that I was like really like
is this real and then sure enough it
wasn't and it's not that I believed it
it's like I'm out there looking for
stuff for us to talk about and it was
like an interesting article and I
questioned it but there's got to be
people out there that didn't question it
and went whoa share check it out in the
story from the conversation which is a
certified legitimate news organization
they say this the top five most believed
satirical claims by the Babylon be they
say and the percentage of Republicans
and Democrats who labeled the claims
definitely true here's the first the
first line most Americans believe that
major media companies should apologize
for pushing the now debunked news story
of collusion between President Trump and
Russia Republicans said it was true 28%
Democrats only six percent it was said
it was true they use these headlines so
that you know it shows you Republicans
you know will believe it's Democrats
well now here we if we if we see the
onion that's a Babylon be here's here's
the the the link they say for the onion
following the passage of Alabama's new
restrictive abortion bill a 12 year old
victim of abuse said during an interview
that she doesn't think she can be a mom
on top of her already hectic life
Republicans didn't believe it Democrats
tended to believe it at 14% now
obviously it's the minority of people
who believe these things right now
here's what makes this so insane that
first line that says most Americans
believe the major media company should
apologize for the Russia story I mean
that sounds absurdly true it was three
years of a fake story that was debunked
in the Moller investigation so I don't
see why someone would think that was not
sure like oh that sounds that sounds
legit no bias well no no but listen it
it's a fact that trust in media is at an
all-time low
right there was a like a member who did
that may have been Pew Research did an
analysis of several different
institutions in the United States from
the military to Congress and the press
had a lower rating than anything else
people absolutely do not trust them so
when you hear that story you're like I
believe it now you want to see where the
fake news comes in so you want to see
you want to see what the real headline
was yeah if I said to you here's the
headline nation awaits apology from
media that pushed fake news story for
two years that's a completely different
headline true so what the study did I'll
do air quotes for study is they changed
the title so that it sounded like real
news instead of satire like it is and
then told people that you know do you
think this is true so if you took a fake
story that said like Donald Trump is a
backflip okay and I said breaking news
Trump's to the backflip people beg
that's not true if they said Donald
Trump was seen performing a physical
maneuver outside the White House they'll
be like oh that sounds like okay what
does that mean yeah I guess yeah I
believe it sure what's a physical
maneuver yeah you can rephrase it in a
way to make it sound more likely to be
real and then if you were like oh it's a
backflip I wouldn't know whey did a
backflip are you nuts right so this is
what the story actually is and what I do
find interesting because one of the
things we started talking about this
before we actually you know pointed out
that they changed the headlines to make
it more believable to claim what the
story is all about is that Snopes kept
fact-checking Babylon being and people
kept making fun of them saying why are
you fact-checking satire it's obviously
fake yeah so Snopes
justified this by doing a bunk study
changing the headlines that to make them
more deceptive and then claiming see
this proves it too many people believe
it therefore we should be doing this
yeah that's the game but then they that
I mean we we talked about Snopes before
where they are talking about not satire
stuff real stuff and like the Hillary
thing did she bleach her emails false
she didn't well that was NBC oh oh that
was NBC yeah yeah I don't know what we
were talking about here's what here's
unlike that here's what Snopes will do
yeah Donald Trump will
make hole-in-one yeah and then everyone
will stay on Twitter Donald Trump made a
hole-in-one and then Snopes will go did
Donald Trump really get a hole-in-one
dot-dot-dot while eating ice cream right
false and then it'll say Trump is well
known for his disdain for chocolate ice
cream and blah blah blah blah and then
all at the bottom will say but while
Trump did hit a hole-in-one he wasn't
eating ice cream while he did it right
here's here's the best part they do the
exact same thing for the left like Greta
toon Berg so it'll so it'll say like
Greta toon Berg wrote an op-ed where she
said it's not really about the
environment it's about ending patriarchy
and colonialism okay and what Babylon
I'm sorry with Snopes will do not
Babylon be with Snopes will do is right
did Greta tune Berg really say she
doesn't care out the environment is
fighting patriarchy and aliens false and
then it'll say like everyone knows
aliens aren't real and it was a meme
that spread claiming that aliens existed
and then Greta bole block at the bottom
while she did say that it's not really
about the environment she didn't mention
aliens once it's a clever faked fake
fact-checking trick these people do yeah
and so so so what I found really
interesting about this though is that so
let me let me pull it the Babylon be the
babylon b is overtly political right its
religion its political its religious and
I started thinking like I feel like you
might have to be politically initiated
and like someone who reads the news and
knows like you know political culture
yeah otherwise you might fall for these
things yeah you might think some of this
is real I mean I've been out of the
picture for a while like I don't I
haven't paid attention more than I have
in the past couple months than ever
obviously you know now I'm now I'm
watching politics and I'm paying
attention to everything that goes on so
that may be why I kind of I was like man
like I don't really know but this is
true like I don't know what Babylon B is
well so let's take a look now I do I do
but let's take a look at the onion it
says here's this story top US health
experts hold on to your effing seats
because this [ __ ] hasn't even thought
about starting yet very obviously fake
yeah I mean it's hilarious it's pretty
good but most of the onion doesn't I
mean they do satirical pop
your stuff oh here's one it was here we
go tulsi gabbard names Democratic
nominee after discovery of obscure rule
that grants nomination to ever win 0.7
percent of the vote in Missouri there's
a lot of political stuff whether there's
something like this girlfriend to make
making playlist of bands you might like
to associate with her forever coworkers
and bathroo sink you know lingering over
whatever things must be getting pretty
serious for girlfriend's dad to gift a
bottle of barbecue sauce you're a
pumpkin head hit [ __ ] announces bus
teenager these are not overtly cultural
political they're just silly jokes and
we say that we're no but whatever
alright you dropped it once and then you
dropped it again I'm like whoa all right
I think I think I think YouTube's gonna
give us the bad hammer anyway for the
coronavirus stuff society's like
whatever you know all right but when you
go to Babylon be mmm Joe Biden anti-gun
activists [ __ ] you no religion raising
your kids yeah it's very very much much
more much more political chick-fil-a
announces new bottle sauce that won't
open oh sorry it doesn't open on Sunday
yeah but they're very different right
Babylon business is going after people
who pay pay attention to the news all
the time right and that means if you're
not someone who follows the news all the
time you might see a story from them and
like Biden says I'll survive the krona
virus just like I survived the Black
Death
that's the lid if you don't know
anything about that you might see then
go huh what well Biden said some crazy
thing why shouldn't that be real but if
you're someone who pays attention you
know that's not real because you know
what Biden's been called that for you've
seen the video you seen what it is and
it's funny what you're talking about but
not talking about I don't know I gotta
say ma'am tired
um you what this is this is a really
great example of a fake study yeah from
a fake fake fact-checking site which has
which was given fact-checking powers by
Facebook to fact-check legitimate news
and then they publish a fake study
that's carried by other news
organizations and they're all claiming
it's real it's like how do you stop it
how do you stop that you're doing it
you're stop dude right okay well it's
people like you it's out there going
this is BS you've got what's going on so
it's right that's why I
my one of my single news sources over
the past like five years pretty much
since I well know made me it four years
or whatever is like you your channel but
it's like it's like the way I see it is
you've got a construction crew with a
crane and they're building a skyscraper
okay and me and a handful of other
people at the bottom hitting with
ball-peen hammers like we're gonna take
this thing down and just getting bigger
and bigger that's a good worse and worse
I mean maybe it's not they'll you know a
lot of people are getting laid off these
companies are falling apart but you look
at how YouTube is censoring certain
words certain names yeah I can't say a
certain name mmm it's ridiculous yeah it
was absolutely crazy but then I'll give
you a really good example there was a
there was a story about this guy and I'm
gonna keep it very dry out I don't get
into too much of details but basically a
guy lied to the press and it was very
obviously alive because the journalist
didn't do any fact-checking right so I
made a video saying dude lies to the
press the video got taken down a day
later The Associated Press issued a
correction saying oops and then a day
later YouTube breach the train say to my
video YouTube has zero respect for
independent creators and commentary and
journalists they would rather burn their
own base to the ground to appease
companies they compete with than to prop
up their authoritative personalities
it's it's it's crazy to me Oh YouTube
that they would YouTube would rather
give CNN and their three-day-old like
three day late news coverage a
promotional spot premium access than
homegrown creators who live for the
platform and so we end up with stuff
like this if as long as YouTube and big
tech companies Twitter and Facebook give
legitimacy to fake news yeah then it
these companies they're supposedly
competing with are always gonna maintain
maintain power push fake stories and use
that influence for their political
agendas for their personal agendas to
make money and then we're just left
sitting here looking at fake news about
a fake study that was published which is
fake news and now you know people
believe it's real it's no up said so
yeah yep even though the onions been
around forever and it's like people
no it's fake I like this disclosure
statement right here it says basically
it's just saying all of these authors
take money from Facebook they received
funding from Facebook it's let's say
that right here disclosure statement
there's no authors right there and then
each each of this is just saying they
take money from Facebook like wow fun
good to know that is good to know
actually the funny thing is recently
Politico ran fake news about the
president okay
and it got facts checked on Facebook and
then all of these progressives are
screeching like I can be used against us
it's not even that it's like wouldn't I
mean dude it's fake the story was fake
did you read the facts check it doesn't
matter it was Tucker Carlson's company
that did it I don't care the true or
isn't fake yeah they're like doesn't
matter Republicans you know what man I'm
so tired of this stuff thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show every
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8:00 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you